last week we heard from so many of you
about that big increase in your gas bill
so today the southwest gas corporation
began a five-day hearing about an
increase to their natural gas utility
service christian casares has been
looking into this matter which has a
whole lot of customers speaking out
again that's right brian denise well
southwest gas is proposing an annual
increase which is actually broken into
two parts now if approved northern
nevada would get a 3.81 percent increase
and southern nevada would be a 5.60
increase now the hearing for this
proposal began this morning and it
continues until friday i reached out to
the public utilities commission and they
told me they do not comment on ongoing
matters they say the approved increase
would impact the average monthly single
family residential bill for natural gas
service in southern nevada by 3.39 or
about 7.44
northern nevada customers can expect a
3.49
charge or about 4.55 percent boost in
their bill now according to the
company's website that increase would
provide a 28.7 million dollar increase
in revenue to cover the company's
current cost to provide safe and
reliable natural gas service here in
nevada now last week hundreds of emails
poured into our newsroom about an
increase in recent bills now in a
statement southwest gas said they
understand customers may be experiencing
natural gas bills which are higher than
expected which is likely due to natural
gas price increases between 2020 and
2021 as well as increased natural gas
usage during the winter months now i
also reached out to southwest gas today
about the proposed rate increase which
if approved would go into effect in
april as of now i'm still waiting for a
response christian gaston is live local
now